William J Cooper jr. why the book titled
Jefferson Davis comma American because I
think that American is the best way to
understand Jefferson Davis Davis always
thought of himself as an American he
thought of himself as a son of the
revolution both ideological and
biological his father's been a
revolutionary soldier he looked at the
Declaration the Constitution as the true
marks of the good American society he
believed in the things that most
Americans of his time did progress
economic growth a geographic development
of the country he believed in all those
things just as most other Americans did
and he never stopped believing in them
fact with the Confederate States of
America of course he's most famous for
being president of Confederacy but he
thought that the Confederate States was
the last best hope for what he believed
the United States was America was before
in his judgment had been subverted by
the Republican Party in the late 1850s
now of course one of the things in his
Americanism was a belief in slavery in
racial slavery he didn't see any
contradiction between America and
slavery slavery had come through the
Revolution intact slavery was protected
by the Constitution
Davis believed that most all other
American South and North believe that
United States Supreme Court and fatica
Lee affirmed that and Davis looked at
the heroes of the nation Washington
Jefferson Madison Andrew Jackson Zachary
Taylor slave owners all and so he didn't
understand why there had to be a
separation over slavery he rejected the
notion that the country couldn't
continue half slave and half free to use
Lincoln's famous phrase because it had
been like that from the beginning and he
thought it could continue like that for
a long time when did he live he lived
from 1808 until 1889 a long time making
him how old when he died he was 81 and a
half how many times was he married twice
first wife first wife was named Sarah
Knox Taylor she was a daughter
the man who became general Zachary
Taylor he was a colonel when Davis met
noxus she was known they were only
married for three months he and she both
contracted malaria a virulent case of
malaria he survived she didn't but he
treasured her memory even late in his
life he he said that he kept a packet of
her letters tied and a bundle in his
house in Mississippi but they were lost
during the war he never saw them after
that but even in his the last two years
of his life he still wrote very fondly
about her second wife second wife was
named Verena Howell and she was a woman
considerably younger than Jefferson
Davis 18 years younger for that matter
he married her early in 1845 when he
married marina of course twice her age
he could have been her father he looked
upon her is almost a reincarnation of
Knox she was young she was vivacious he
was madly in love with her but their
marriage was not all roses there was
some difficulties in their marriage
because arena was not a little girl for
very long and she wanted to be taken as
a serious woman and that posed difficult
is for Jefferson and particularly for
his oldest brother Joseph who was a
surrogate father to him how many
children did he have Davis and Verina
had a total of six children the lives
were that children especially the boys
were very sad the first boy died in
infancy the second boy was a four of
them all four sons died before Davis the
next one who died was during the Civil
War who died of an accident then a boy
died in 18 in their 1870's of diphtheria
and his oldest son Jeff jr.
died in 1878 of yellow fever and he was
only 21 where was he born
Jefferson Davis yes he was born in
Kentucky in south-central Kentucky not
far above the Tennessee line and not
that far from where Bram Lincoln was
born where was he living most of his
life he lived most of his life in
Mississippi his father was a man who
followed tried to find the American
dream following the frontier he started
off in joy
moved to Kentucky in the 1790s early in
the nineteenth century shortly after
Davis's birth and age 8 he moved on west
stopped for a moment in Louisiana and
then ended up in the southwestern corner
of Mississippi Wilkinson County to the
little town of Woodville and that was
where Davis's boyhood home was and he he
moved from after school and law he came
back to Mississippi he lived near his
brother Joseph on their plantations up
near the town of Vicksburg right on the
river you say in your book he was a
wealthy man he wasn't wealthy man for
his time
absolutely it's impossible to chart his
income precisely but he was making in
the neighborhood of thirty five to forty
thousand dollars a year from his
plantation in the late 1850s of course
the new income taxes and it's difficult
to say dollar-for-dollar but that's
considerably more than $35,000 now at a
time the average income for a worker in
Mississippi a white worker was like two
hundred two dollars so he was a wealthy
man for his time how many slaves did he
own he owned just over one hundred
slaves in 1860 he'd started with one in
the 1830s he had one slave man he
inherited from his father and this slave
was a fascinating character within for
Davis his name was James Pemberton
he followed Davis in the army he was
Davis's body servant as they will call
when Davis was in the Army in the 1830s
as a professional soldier when he went
back to Mississippi to begin farming
James Pemberton started farming with him
helped him open up his plantation and
became his first overseer and Davis was
one of the few planters who used a slave
overseer and permit and remained is over
signal 1850 when he died after
Pemberton's death Davis never had any
success with overseas he went through
them almost annually after 1850 all
white men but he never found one who
worked as well for him as Pemberton did
what did mr. Pemberton do as is what was
it to Kermie years the body he serve God
he served he would be in our days now we
are Val a cook or them in the Army yeah
take care of the horses and at that time
the army provided on the salary schedule
I mean he got money to pay for James
Pemberton's
you could have a servant or slave a
slave could be your servant in the
professional army and had been officer
yes and did all officers have no officer
didn't but they could if they chose to
now where did he go to school his life
well if you want to start from the very
beginning and I'd like to start from the
beginning because I think it's
fascinating
his parents were Baptist and he grew up
in the southwestern corner Mississippi
yet as a little boy of 8 years old he
went all the way back to Kentucky to a
private school a Catholic a Roman
Catholic private school where he stayed
for a couple of years and then he can't
he he left Mississippi his mother Tina
was going his father decided they wanted
the boy to have the best education you
could have he didn't think there was
anything down there where he was it was
was fitting so he sent him back up to
Kentucky mother to know he'd left he
came back to our Mississippi and he was
in a couple of academies near Woodville
until he was 16 and then he went to
Transylvania University in Lexington
Kentucky which was the first major
American educational institution west of
the Appalachian Mountains it was a
first-class University back in the early
20s when Davis went and again you could
see his father had a great interest in
his education so that was a long way to
go from southwestern Mississippi to
Kentucky in the in the 18 teens
he went to Transylvania he flourished at
Transylvania he did well academically
did well socially but his father died
while he was there and his oldest
brother Joseph who was 24 years older
than Jefferson Jefferson was the tenth
of ten children and Joseph became a
surrogate father for him and Joseph
wanting to go to West Point Joseph was
very ambitious for Davis and Davis said
okay I really don't want to go but if
you want me to go he was a dutiful son
and brother and so he said I'll go and
he went to West Point he stayed for
years finishing the class of 1828 but he
he didn't get along too well in the
regimented world of West Point he had a
lot of trouble he was in serious trouble
a couple of times he had some accidents
from drinking too much he almost got
thrown out of the school but he did
finish in 1828 with a commission in the
army
what rank was he in his class he was I
don't remember the exact rank but he was
not toward the top
was toward the bottom I think I have it
written down it it's like 163 out of 208
or something well that was in his
conduct because they weren't that many
in his class in his class would have
been fewer than 50 people
Westport was a very small place we don't
realize how small colleges were back
then West Point had using no more than
250 students at one time on the post and
they were only allowed to leave once in
four years I mean it was really a
military monastery and those boys really
got to know one another and that sort of
a close proximity and of course Davis
was there with a number of people that
would later become quite well-known when
he was president of Confederacy like
Robbie Lee was a class behind so was
Joseph e Johnston Albert Sidney Johnston
was a couple of classes ahead of him
when they were convinced they became all
three of those people became Confederate
generals any Union generals at his time
none of the ones who became famous all
the famous Union generals came after
Davis's time you know people like grant
Sherman McClellan shared and they were
all at West Point much after Davis's
time the name Jefferson Davis come from
any place special it came from Thomas
Jefferson who's named for Thomas
Jefferson his father was an art and
Jeffersonian and politics and he named
his final child tenth child for Thomas
Jefferson who was the sitting president
when Jefferson Davis was born what
different jobs did he have in his life
Jefferson Davis yes mainly the political
jobs for now the political jobs well he
started off this first political job
successful job he was chosen as an
elector for the state of Mississippi in
1844 now that's different from now now
somebody's elect oh it's the political
plumb and you get your name on the
ballot you don't do much else but back
then you expected your campaign and
Davis went out and campaigned throughout
Mississippi in 1844 just as if he were
running for office himself and he
campaign successfully James K Polk was
elected president 1844 the Democrat then
the very next year 1845 Davis ran for
Congress and he ran on a general ticket
that is it
Mississippi didn't have districts the
law permitted estate to have general
tickets back then so he had to campaign
all across the state to get elected he
was elected to Congress in 1845 he
resigned from Congress
to go into Mexican War he came back from
Mexico as a senator from 1847 in 1851 he
resigned to run for governor Mississippi
was defeated became Secretary of War
1853 under Franklin Pierce and Pierce's
administration of office in 1857 Davis
went back to the Senate and he was in
the Senate when the Union broke apart in
1860 61 and then of course he became
president of the Confederacy for how
long was he president four years he was
elected for six but the Confederacy
didn't last but four and he's buried
where he is buried in Richmond Virginia
with all members of his family his wife
and his children all buried in Richmond
and Hollywood Cemetery the 195
he start out here by on Christmas Day
1847 the two men had an altercation that
resulted in violence well this has to do
with a man named Henry S Foote who was a
great opponent of Jefferson Davis and
Mississippi politics Davis and Foote
started off getting along pretty well in
the beginning they were both sort of
rising stars amongst Mississippi
Democrats and they campaigned together
for example in 44 for President Polk but
thereafter they they fell out had to do
with personality difficulties more than
with political difficulties in the
beginning Davis felt Foote accused him
of on truths and claimed that he had
been a coward and had done he and Foote
had a fight and it was papered over by
friends and after that they still had
difficulties Davis felt foot was
challenging his honor and his honor as a
man his integrity as a man and Davis
wanted to fight a duel with foot but he
was talked out of fighting a duel by
saying that look on the one hand foots
not worth it on the second hand that
you're a military man and such and
people will look upon you not favorably
because they think you have an unfair
advantage over foot and then politically
they fell out completely in 1850 and 51
over the compromise of 1850 in the
direction of Mississippi politics and
Foote had one great moment against Davis
he beat Davis for governor in 1851
but political gods didn't shine on foot
in the political world change shortly
after that and foot left Mississippi
with the California came back to
Tennessee and during the Civil War he
was a Confederate senator from Tennessee
and still fighting Jefferson Davis on
that page so you say things like after
friends separated them foot started to
leave but at the door turned announcing
he had struck first yeah you know he was
trying to say that Davis was a coward
you know that Davis had not defended
himself but Davis was not willing to be
the kind of man southerners Valiant
honored so much they've a an honor so
much and honor headed had a twin twin
component you had to believe in yourself
that you were a man of integrity
independence and you would stand for
yourself as a man but also you had to
perceive it it had to be perceived in
the larger world it just couldn't be in
turn had to be external so these two
come together and so if somebody would
have say to you well you were a coward
you don't do things properly you may
know in yourself but that's not true and
you say you're lying but in the world
Davis lived in the larger world had to
see that as well and so Davis had I mean
he felt he had to act this was nothing
unique about Davis this was the world in
which he lived in the concept of Honor
was a powerful powerful social force in
his world what would be the difference
between a foot Democrat and a Davis
Democrat in Mississippi well there would
have been no measurable difference
except in terms of liking one man over
another a personal difference until 1850
in the compromise of 1850 which had to
do chiefly with how the country was
gonna handle what was called the Mexican
Cession the territory gained from the
Mexican War which included all of the
current Southwest plus California and
the fight was about slavery would
slavery be permitted to go in to the
Mexican Cession
the nation had moved westward from the
revolution across the Appalachian
Mountains across the Mississippi River
slavery had moved westward all the way
from the eastern seaboard to Texas well
the Mexican Cession comes west of Texas
there had been a law passed in eighteen
the Missouri Compromise which controlled
how slavery could expand westward in the
Louisiana territory which went all the
way to Canada
but the Louisiana territory was like a
funnel it was narrow at the bottom and
broadened out to go up to Canada along
the Rocky Mountains was his western
border but the Southwest was not a part
of Louisiana now we've got all that
Southwest out there southerners wanted
to take slaves out there they wanted the
right to take slaves not the issue is
not so much whether they would take them
but they wanted the right to take them
and the compromise of 1850 was there was
no guarantee that southerners could take
slaves out there in fact it was a
guarantee that they couldn't take them
to California the way it was set up and
foot supported the compromise of 1850
Davis opposed it bitterly they fought
each other in Congress both members of
the Senate back in Mississippi they took
opposing sides and they fought each
other for governor Mississippi in 1851
of contest as I said a little bit
earlier that on that foot one how did
you get into all this and how long did
this take you 700 pages well I've been
interested in Jefferson Davis a very
long time I was a senior in college I
wrote my senior thesis on an aspect of
Jefferson Davis in the Civil War I went
to graduate school I thought I might
like to try to write about Jefferson
Davis and I was given very good advice
by my major professor he said look
you're not ready to write a book about a
man like Davis pick some part of his
career I write about Davis is Secretary
of War that that just didn't interest me
at all at that time and so I turned away
from Davis and did many other things
where did you go to graduate school
Johns Hopkins University and I am did
many other things I mainly about
southern politics before the Civil War
and Davis was always a character and in
the 80s I decided I worked on a book
that was I become an administrator to my
University and I worked on a general
history of the south and I finished that
and I said well you know if you ever
gonna do Davis you've got to try now so
I decided to give it a shot and I
started here 1988 and this is what
school your
Minister Louisiana State University in
Baton Rouge yes and uh I started on this
book in 1988 it came out last fall so it
was 12 years from the time I began til
the book was published on the back you
have at least four people have been
heard on this program who are all
historians and they say things like this
David Herbert Donald who wrote Lincoln
and says William J Cooper's Jefferson
Davis American is one of the most
impressive biographies published in the
last decade
you know David um yes I do know David
Donald ah he was my major professor in
graduate school I've known David for a
long time at Johns Hopkins correct and
and did did you ask him to say something
that's strong well no I didn't ask him
to say anything I the publisher my
publisher got these uh comments so I'd
be my guess all I can tell you my
publisher got these comments I
appreciate all the comments thrown the
book well James McPherson says Jefferson
Davis lived 77 of is 81 years as an
American and only four as president of
confetti yet it is for those four years
he is chiefly remembered William J
Cooper's splendid biography the best yet
does good service in reminding us that
even during his years at war with the
United States
Davis professed to be fighting for
American institutions and ideals as he
understood them James McPherson says
this is the best of 16 well there are at
least 16 depending on how you count
Davis has been the almost you can say
the victim of many biographers on many
Davis biographers have been either very
Pro very anti what are you I uh I am
neither I try to be understanding
I'm not Pro Davis I'm not any Davis my
goal was to try to understand Davis but
to understand him as a man of his time I
mean he's not a man of the 21st century
he's a man of the 19th century and I
tried to understand him as a man at his
time how hard was this to do well it was
it was very hard to do but it was it was
fascinating to do I never lost interest
in Jefferson Davis I found Davis an
absolutely fascinating man and my
interest never flagged how did you go
about it well
first I should say is probably couldn't
have done this except for the Jefferson
Davis Association which is housed at
Rice University that's where the
Jefferson the letterpress edition the
modern edition of the Jefferson Davis
papers are being published like some of
the George Washington papers and all
these they have there at Rice and the
editor of the Davis papers at Rice it
was very generous to me she permitted me
to come there she permitted me to make
use of all the documents they have and
they have collected and rice almost
every known Davis document so I didn't
have to go to 40 libraries United States
looking for Davis materials they're not
alive looking for other materials I mean
it's not represent why rice why in
Houston well chiefly because there was a
historian at Rice by the name of Frank
Vandiver who is a Dean of Davis scholars
and when Frank was at Rice he was very
interested in Davis and when in the 50s
the early 60s when all these papers
projects really got underway many of
them got underway he was instrumental in
setting up a project at Rice for Davis
and finding money to to help fund it and
the university to come in and support it
so that's why I said right as we said
that the strong endorsements by other
historians what do you think they saw in
this that makes it the best
I think perhaps two things I mean it's
based on an awful lot of research I mean
his stories respect research and I have
done a lot of work nobody told me to go
back to the library I've done a lot of
work the second thing is I think that
they see it as an even-handed attempt to
understand Davis this is not a book that
says Davis was the most wonderful person
who ever lived
but it's also not a book who says he's a
devil incarnate he was a man who like
other men had strengths and weaknesses
he lived through extraordinary difficult
times he was a man who had enormous
ambition and drive and determination and
I think that these historians see that
I'm trying to deal with him on his own
terms and fit him in his time how often
were you truly surprised by what you
found
I was surprised on several occasions I
was surprised on several occasion I was
very surprised that Jefferson Davis had
such difficulty with overseers when I
began this I didn't really know very
much about Davis and James Pemberton I
was in I knew vaguely that Pemberton had
been an overseer for him that's all I
really knew define one over CR the
overseer was a person on the plantation
who was usually a white man with the man
between the owner and the slaves the
owner would tell the overseer these are
the jobs that have to be done it's the
overseers job to the hands-on management
of the slaves to get the work done I
didn't realize that Pemberton had such a
central role in Davis's plantation
management and then upon his death I had
no idea that Davis had so much
difficulty with overseers that that was
not uncommon many southern planters had
difficulty with overseers they had
difficulty finding an overseer hootsie
obviously has had two tasks that were
often contradictory owners would tell
them make the best crop you can you make
me the most money you can't but then
they would say we don't want a slave for
us that's unhappy that's angry you know
keep the slaves as contended as you can
always keep them as reasonably content
as you can these these two often clashed
and slaves understood that they had a
relationship with the other that the
owner would respect I mean the slave
owner would much rather have an overseer
he had to fire than a bunch of slaves
over here who are unhappy not willing to
work so what we're saying was a tough
job and but slave owners had difficulty
finding an overseer who could keep both
those in balance why was he having so
much trouble all slave owners did Davis
was not unusual but I was surprised to
find that he had that difficulty because
received wisdom about his plantation was
that it was sort of almost an idle a
monk on a Dilek place on the southern
plantation scene I didn't find that to
be true but I was surprised about the
overseer let me ask you about names
ask about some more surprises in
hurricane hurricane was the name of his
oldest brother Joseph's plantation where
was that it was in Warren County
Mississippi just south of Vicksburg and
I was on Mississippi River that was on a
piece of land called Davis been there
was a real peninsular that jutted out in
the river from Mississippi the river
made a great loop to the west around
Davis bin that's what Joseph's
plantation Harkin was and right next to
it was Jefferson's plantation Briarfield
now it's Davis Island because in 1867
the river cut it off and it's just an
island in the middle of the Mississippi
River now what's Beauvoir well wha is
the last home Davis had it's down on the
Mississippi Gulf Coast
it's where he spent the last dozen years
of his life he moved there in 1877 at
the behest of the woman who owned it a
woman named Sarah Dorsey a woman whose
family he had known he had known her too
in the antebellum years she was younger
than Davis and she revered Davis and
when he width in 1877 he really had no
place else to go he his business career
attempt to have a business career after
the war had collapsed and he determined
how to try to write his memoir the
Confederacy and there's dorsey offered
him a place to go he went there and then
she agreed to sell it to him
she didn't give it to him she agreed to
sell it on favorable terms of her but
then she died and left it to him in her
will so he inherited Beauvoir and he
lived there until he died in 1889
now you say at one point that I mean I
remember the statement there was no
evidence that they ever had a physical
relationship why would you even have to
say that because a lot of people implied
that they did and people looking back at
from our point in history would say that
a man and a woman who were living like
that that point in time you know living
like that so close together and she
obviously revered him that it's almost
without saying that they would have won
where was Farina well when he first
moved to Beauvoir Farina was still in
Europe they had been in Europe and she
was still over there when they'd been
there together she had taken ill and
then she had a sister who lived in
England a younger sister and she
remained in England and Davis came back
and moved down with
Miz Dorsey and Rina didn't like that at
all
she was bitter and angry about it and
when she came back to this country she
announced that she was in no way ever
going to live that well she realized
that she really had no choice that her
husband had no place else to go if he
wanted to write this book and she
eventually went to Beauvoir and over
time she and Sarah Dorsey reconciled and
she became a strong supporter of Sarah
Dorsey who had nursed marina during a
period of serious illness for marina you
mentioned brother Joseph and marina and
you at some point the book you also
talked about a triangle yeah three of
them rise going on among the three of
them well the two people Jefferson Davis
cherished motion of the world with
Joseph his oldest brother as I've said
several times almost his father and his
wife Farina Joseph was so important to
Davis for so many reasons not only was
Joseph instrumental is going to West
Point when Davis came resigned from the
Army in 1835 and came back to
Mississippi Joseph gave him the land
that became his plantation in Brockville
Davis did not have to pay one penny for
it now Joseph didn't give him title to
it but he gave him the land and said you
can have this Joseph helped him with his
initial purchase of slaves to get
started
Joseph and he were very close on all
kinds of matters they talked about
intellectual subjects together they were
involved in plantation matters together
they were politically active Joseph was
very politically active in Mississippi
Democratic Party and he gave Davis
entree to politics well Jefferson and
marina met when marina was visiting
Joseph whom she called Uncle Joe Marina
marinas father and Joseph Davis were
closed well Joseph Davis was ought to be
Farina's grandfather and he looked upon
her as a child well when they married
when Jefferson Barracks freedom Joseph
still looked upon her as a child
Brina wanted to be taken as an adult
woman Joseph never really did that again
that seperates in an age at marriage the
separation was now between Joseph and
Verina would have been over 40 years
between Jefferson Marina was almost 20
years she
like 1718 and he was on 3536 when they
marriage so but Joseph is another 24
years older than Jefferson so and her
relationship with Joseph is very tense
and when Jefferson goes to the Mexican
War Joseph does not want the land that
Jefferson is farming to end up in
marinas hands so legal things are set up
so that Verena can live on the land of
Jefferson should die until her death but
she can't own it and that made her very
very angry with with Joseph and
Jefferson in fact had to come back from
Mexico on one occasion to try to deal
with a real difficulty between Joseph
and marina let me read a just a couple
of paragraphs here from your book
talking about the tomb their
relationship between marina and her
husband Jefferson was blunt I will be
frank with you he wrote from Washington
about why he had refused to bring her
with him even though he headed north
quote with body crippled even shattered
mind oppressed unquote he had felt
compelled to go without her because his
dread of constant strife was so great
first I want to ask you also read a
little bit more body crippled even
shattered and mind depressed why well
the body was crippled because of his
wound in the Mexican War and the Battle
of buenavista Davis was wounded in the
heel and he was never a life-threatening
wound but it caused a great deal of
physical pain and it impaired his
walking for a while he was very
depressed because of the situation
between his wife and his brother and
between his wife and himself that's why
he was depressed we say here this is
more quotes I cannot bear constant
harassment this is Jefferson Davis
saying this occasional reproach and
subsequent misrepresentation to him his
wife's misdeeds had been numerous and
serious her attitude about the house her
not caring for him when he was hurt her
grumbling about her servants then
becoming angry when he found a kind
companion Amanda it was his system to
take charge of the household on and on
what was their relationship probably
like well at this point in time the
relationship was very very tense and I
think it bottomed it had to do with
Joseph because it was the they were in
close proximity Joseph in Briarfield the
house they lived in was a mile from the
house
the Joseph lived in and Davis said
Verena could have a new house the house
was being constructed at this was not
the new house wasn't built by this time
but his sister was to come and help
Freda who had been complaining she had
too much work to do Jefferson got
disgusted he said look you either behave
and by they behave he meant like I want
you to behave or else and he left in
Mississippi
now she loved being in Washington
she loved wash with of time they came in
1845 to Congress she was taken with the
Capitol she liked Washington a whole lot
better and she liked Warren County
Mississippi so to leave her at home was
a real slap in her face and Davis says
it a couple times in this period that
I'm late for is it you know we we may
not be able to live together he would
never contemplate a divorce but you easy
we just might have to be separate or not
this lasted for a time and Barina
started reading popular self health book
self-help books at that time to try to
be a better wife and those books were
teló woman to be submissive and to take
the station that God had given her and
be happy there and that sort of thing
but over time their relationship changed
they didn't stay in one place by the
mid-50s the davis and his wife had
become much closer and then during the
war they became very close companions i
should say there was one other thing
Brina Brina had not yet had a child and
in her culture the main job of a healthy
young woman was to have a family and she
had not yet had a child and she'd been
married several years and there's
there's not a whole lot of evidence but
there's some evidence that this did
bother her which is understandable
physically what did Jefferson Davis look
like in person do you think how big was
he he was about 511 6 feet tall he was
very spare he never weighed more than
like 145 pounds and he was an erect
person he had a
a military posture which he obviously
got at West Point as a young man and it
stayed with him he was always very
people commented on high erect his
carriage and bearing was we've got a
picture of him as a young man did he
change much it'll come up in a second
that he changed much between the time he
was younger yes I think you will see a
change this is him this is a picture of
Davis probably somewhere in the mid
eighteen thirties to 1840 it's before
he's married to Verena you see even in
this picture the thing that what the
feature that leaps out at me is his eyes
his eyes look like they have real the
penetrate they look like eyes that are
thinking and imagining now as you go on
in his life you will see changes in his
face we have him in 1853 which would
it'll come up in a second how would he
have been then in 1853 he's about 45
years old this is when he's becoming
Secretary of War you can see here you
can see that his face is aged and yet
he's got a village there that a
confidence and himself
Kotter's in his own power again the eyes
I think dominate just a image there's a
problem with an eye well the eye problem
gets really bad after this he has had
some Alfama logic difficulties before
now but in the late fifties he has
serious problems with his left eye and a
film develops over his left eye by the
late 50s this picture is probably 53 and
he had a serious attack in 51 but he has
not developed this film yet and he he
will eventually basically lose sight in
that eye you know he can't pick out
distinct things in his left eye this is
a picture area here in the book from
about 1858 yes that that picture is
taken probably after the serious are
difficulties you had in the spring of
1857 which was the most serious our
problems you had
in his life and the aftermath of that
this film does develop and you notice in
this picture that she's showing him the
book his face is turned a bit it's not a
full frontal face and that picture plus
the famous Matthew Brady photograph
which is on the cover of the book
you see his turn for the left eye is not
facing the camera and that's because of
this film and people comment on the film
now neuralgia is mentioned often yeah
what is it and how much of it did he
have well
his neurologist probably was a
manifestation the malaria he had as a
young man he had malaria in 1835 the
same disease that killed his first wife
NOx and he had malaria for the rest of
his life manifestations of it occurred
regularly chills fevers neuralgia nerve
difficulties Davis in many ways was a
person who was ill most of the time
given the state of Medicine in the
middle of the nineteenth century it's
nothing short of astonishing they smoked
cigars all the time even more when he
was sick did he never stop smoking
cigars he never stopped smoking cigars
he smoked pipes often - but cigars most
often well that he never made the
connection between bronchial
difficulties and cigars or he didn't
care I'm not sure but he smoked them all
of his life as badly as these
biographies go this is 700 pages how big
are the others
and you know there oh yes oh yes well
the about 660 pages of text the rest is
notes oh yes there's a three-volume
biography of Davis published in the mid
50's there's a big fat to volume
biography of Davis published in the
1930s the - immediately preceding this
of this length so they've been some fat
ones where is your hometown originally I
grew up in Williamsburg County South
Carolina and how much education do I
have a PhD in what history where'd you
get that Johns Hopkins and why LSU in
Baton Rouge what got you there well when
I was looking for a job that was the job
that seemed to me the best opportunity I
had at that time and so I went there and
they've been very good to me and I've
stayed there what is your job I am a
professor in history department
shooter Louisiana State University and
how long you been there 32 years now
since 1968 let's go back to 1860 yeah
what is Jefferson Davis doing them he's
the United States Senator what's the
atmosphere the atmosphere is one of
tremendous political tension the
presidential election of 1860 most
Americans feel will be tremendously
important for the future of the country
the Republican Party ran first its first
candidate four years previously and
almost won and the Republicans were a
sectional party there were no
southerners in the Republican party the
Republicans whole strategy for winning
was if you could carry the north you
need the south this was a new phenomenon
in American history and it frightened
something's because they had always been
instrumental in American political
parties they'd been at the top and the
Democratic Party was their party in 1860
but the Democrats also had tremendous
strength in the north but northern and
southern democrats were divided over
personalities and divided over issues in
1860 so the Democratic Party split there
was a northern candidate with southern
candidate this three is not enough
there's the fourth candidate because
people who didn't like Republicans or
Democrats mostly old wigs they put up a
candidate there were four people running
they had Stephen Douglas he's a northern
Democrat and Lincoln is a Republican
John C Breckinridge is a southern
Democrat and John Bell is a candidate of
a group that call themselves a
constitutional unist who did Jefferson
Davis support he supported John C
Breckinridge Davis was also active in
the effort to try to get all the poets
and Republicans to unite behind a new
candidate that is for Belle Douglas and
Breckinridge all free to drop out to
find somebody new and sort of neutral to
come in and take the standard to run
against the Republican that all failed
as you know is so much to cover in very
little time so I'm going to jump around
just so we can get some of this stuff in
for the hours over the what was the
moment in the Senate where
and Davis says I got it I got to leave
this I got to go back to the silo he
Mississippi seceded early in the month
of January in 1816 1861 Davis had fought
against secession he believed in
secession he believed it was
constitutionally proper it was
sanctioned by the Constitution he never
thought it was an unconstitutional act
but he never wanted it to come about in
fact after Lincoln's election in 1860
the government of Mississippi called
together in Jackson the capital of the
state the congressional delegation to
consult with him about what he should
propose to the state legislature amongst
those people in that meeting Davis was
the only one who was not for immediate
secession he went Washington he tried
hard to find some way to come up with a
compromise that would keep things doing
at least for a while and of course his
compromise always had to be with a
guarantee the South could have its
constitutional rights in the territories
that is that there was a right for
southerners to take their slave property
to the territories how big a deal was a
slave part of all this the slave part
was a very big deal and why because well
there was several reasons why slavery
was absolutely central in the southern
society economy
slavery was central in southern
political power because the Constitution
through the three-fifths provision
counted slaves three-fifths of slaves
for representation that meant
congressmen and votes in the electoral
college it was in slavery was important
for political power slavery was also
important to southerners because slavery
was American there was nothing wrong
with slavery in southerner soil in the
Constitution protected slavery slavery
had come through from the Declaration
through the Revolution the American
heroes I've just gone through that
before people like Jackson or Washington
were slave owners there was nothing
wrong with slavery so they didn't look
upon slavery as something bad or
something that they should be ashamed of
not at all so the circumstances in the
United States Senate today he stood up
to say I'm out
here yeah well this came after he
received formal notice from Mississippi
that the state had seceded he didn't
leave just when he got the telegraphic
report that Mississippi yes it's acceded
he waited for the formal notification
from the state and then he went and he
stood up in the Senate and he said that
he said it was packed people were in the
Senate it was almost a spectator sport
in this winter of crisis said it was
packed he stood up and he said it was
time for him to say goodbye that his
state had seceded because the
Constitution and the Declaration had
been subverted by the Republicans as he
saw it that people knew his belief about
secession that even if he didn't think
Mississippi was right he would have to
go but he thought Mississippi had the
right to do what he did and then he said
goodbye he looked at people and he said
if you know if I still things that I
have between us that we haven't settled
I settle them all now I'm leaving who
are his best friends and a son then his
best friends in the Senate or several
people are Clement clay from Alabama and
one of his friends in the Senate was
William Seward from New York who was a
major Republican who was the most
important national republican and who
expected to be the Republican Cave of
prayers in 1860 until he was passed over
Fabri ham Lincoln Davis's friendship
with Seward as fascinating unfortunate
that there's not a lot of documentary
evidence for what passed between them
but when Davis was sick and 57 when he
had this terrible eye problems
Seward visited him regularly every say
every day every day well every day visit
him every day and I think Davis believed
in 1860 when the crisis came that maybe
he and Seward could work something out
because he believed that Seward was
willing to make a deal
and Seward was a powerful nationalist
and Seward had so much cachet in the
north that he thought Seward might could
make it would Seward wouldn't do
anything without Lincoln what again what
was the day that he resigned you
remember I think it was a 21st of
January or the 20th of January how long
did it take him to be elected
to be the president of the Confederacy
about three weeks he was chosen
president and Federer see I buy the
group of men who met in Montgomery
Alabama in February 1861
to create the Confederate States of
America and there were how many states
there six states met the South China
Georgia Alabama Mississippi Florida
Louisiana Texas also seceded but the
Texas delegates didn't get to Montgomery
by the time Davis was selected and the
voting was by States each state had one
vote and Davis won that unanimous Davis
brought to that office qualifications
nobody else could match how did they get
then from Montgomery to Richmond
well after Virginia seceded and it was a
great victory for the Confederates when
Virginia did secede Virginia did not
secede and laughter Fort Sumter after
Lincoln call for volunteers to put down
the rebellion then Virginia seceded but
Confederates thought Virginia was the
mother of the South Virginia was a home
of the great heroes of the American
Revolution aside from that Richmond
Virginia was the most important
industrial city in the Confederate
States and Montgomery was small and
really one big enough to handle what the
growth of the capital and so in May of
1861 the capital was moved to Montgomery
they have a to route to Richmond from
Richmond did they have a white house
they did not have a white house but a
house mansion in Richmond was bought by
the city of Richmond and then given to
the Confederate States to use for the
Executive Mansion and they have a
Congress yes they had a Congress that
caused the center that they had a house
and a Senate now they may be careful
here or mislead in Montgomery the where
the provisional Congress met there was a
balk at only one unicameral but when the
provisional Congress had run its course
and then the Confederate Constitution
called for the election of a Congress
that was a bicameral Congress House and
Senate just like the United States and
it met and in the Virginia State Capitol
it was where admit it we're going to
avoid talking a lot about the war years
only because we've discussed that a lot
in this program and I want to jump if
you don't mind to the near the
and they were losing and when how that
this country treated Jefferson Davis at
the end and where he lived and all that
what it let me just ask you this general
question why do you think he lost or the
country he was leading lost in the Civil
War I think they lost because they were
they were beaten by a much stronger
power that used everything at its
command to defeat the Confederates now
you know a lot of people who say the
Confederates lost because there was
disaffection the Confederates in that
confession have a will to win and they
look to the Vietnam War when the
stronger pol United States didn't win
thus and they look to the American
Revolution when the stronger power Great
Britain didn't win and the answer is
well because southerners in wanted bad
enough they don't tend to look at the
Germans in the Japanese in World War two
both of whom were beaten to a pulp
I think the southerners the Confederates
was was smashed I mean the North used
everything it had all of its
overpowering force it had as its
commander-in-chief
Lincoln was unrelenting Lincoln was
determined Lincoln was not going to back
away and Lincoln found generals who
would use the enormous power they had
did they ever meet by the way Lincoln
and David has never met and we're at the
end of the Civil War where was Jefferson
Davis well he was on the run he was
trying very hard to get to Texas he
hoped to carry on the war and what the
Confederates call the trans-mississippi
that area west of the Mississippi River
he hoped to get their overland or if he
couldn't get the overland at least to
get to Florida and take a boat to Mexico
and come up to Texas through Mexico but
he was captured by Union Cal vermin in
South Georgia and May of 1861 what they
do with it well they made him a prisoner
and he was taken up to Macon and put on
a train and carriage from Macon to
Augusta put on a boat carried to
Savannah and eventually ended up in
Fortress Monroe which is at the
confluence of the James River in the
Chesapeake Bay down there at Virginia
village village he was in prison there
for two years
18 May 1865 to May 1867
how was he treated
well initially was treated pretty
harshly uh he was brought in they put
irons on him he fought that physically
the putting ions on him but they didn't
last very long at the most for five days
but he was incarcerated in a case mate
that means in the inner walls of the
other of the fortress and he had a steel
door that a century looking at him every
second of every day there was not one
moment of privacy for anything whatever
that lasted until the fall and in the
fall of 1865 he was moved into an
apartment fitted for him in officers
quarters in a building at Fortress
Monroe how suspicious was Andrew Johnson
of Jefferson Davis and the assassination
of Abraham Lincoln well President
Johnson and many other northern leaders
believe that Davis had been involved
they had been bad blood between Andrew
Johnson and Jefferson Davis long before
the Civil War when Davis got word that
Lincoln had been assassinated he
expressed the opinion that did neither
he know the South would could expect
much forbearance from Andrew Johnson
where they in the Senate together they
were in the Senate together and the
house together two before they were in
senator young Andrew Johnson from
Tennessee he was a Democrat like Davis
but he looked upon Davis as a member of
the planter class and he was not a
member of the panel class and he didn't
like Davis personally was he indicted
Davis was indicted he was indicted for
treason
he was never brought to trial his um his
captors couldn't decide what to do they
were afraid to bring him a trial in part
because they were afraid if a jury would
wouldn't convict him with acquit him
then the whole northern rationale for
fighting the war that secession was
constitutional be thrown out by a jury
they didn't want to lose and also had
problems were the judges the Chief
Justice would sit on the circuit court
in Richmond the Chief Justice of the
United States Senator chase and they
were worried that Chase might decide for
Davis and so for the federal government
there were people inside the federal
government who felt that Davis should
never be brought to trial that the war
was over and that he should be let go
and so there was a conflict had there
been a jury trial and Richmond
and salmon P chase set had been sitting
presiding would there have been a jury
of southern oh yes the jury would have
come from Richmond and ironically
Davis's attorneys were very afraid of a
jury trial too they were afraid that the
jury would have on it people who were
Republicans even blacks and they would
vote to convict Davis not on the merits
of the case but just on Davis when does
he get out of prison May 1867 he is
paroled where does he go well he goes to
Canada his family has been in Canada he
goes to Canada for a few months and then
desperate to try to make a living to try
to find some way to earn money he goes
to England trying to sell interest in
Canadian mines that's why he goes to
England how old is he about this time
well he's approaching 60 years old he's
approaching his health like his health
is really not that much worse than it's
been I mean he had intensive medical
care in the in prison in fact because of
claims made that he had suffered so as a
prisoner the Secretary of War declared
that Davis must be examined everyday and
the official records has you can look at
him the medical reports by day in Davis
is doing about like he's always a bit
older so going to weaker but he's not
that much how many children at this
point at this point he has got four
children two sons and two daughters and
he goes to England anyplace else over
Europe that it did well he travels in
France he travels in Scotland but
England and he stays mostly in England
though do they think of him over there
well in England he is royally received
many in the English upper classes had
been Pro compared to their sentiments
and Davis was really lionized but he and
his wife had a serious problem because
they had very little money in Marina
especially was very anxious about
getting involved in a social world in
which she could not move as an equal in
which she could not reciprocate so they
really didn't how does he get the job in
ants with the insurance company well he
gets the job with the insurance company
because of friends who talk to him about
it and put him up for it they know he's
got to find some way to make a living
he's not
succeeding in England she comes back to
this country but he's very unsure about
getting an insurance business on he says
what will people think of him becoming
just an insurance man that status will
drop and he his wife is concerned about
that and there's a wonderful exchange of
letters between them on this matter and
Davis finally says look says I
understand how things are but look I got
to make a living said I'd much rather be
a college president and I had an offer
from Sawada University of the southeast
I don't pay enough money so he says um
I'm going to take this job and he says
I'll make enough that if you don't want
to come and live in Memphis with me you
can live someplace else until we can do
better for our salon did he do that
he did that for basically three years
and then how did they finally get back
to Beauvoir well he got back to Bo he
got to Beaufort not back out there the
first time because mrs. Dorsey invited
him to come they offered him a place to
live and he went there to write what
became rise and fall the Confederate
states and you say he was there the last
three years of his life that's 12 years
of his life I'm sorry that's 12 years of
his life how much money did he make off
his book and it itself amazing and this
was you ask about surprises early on and
we didn't get back to that that's one of
the things that really surprised me how
many at books all over 20,000 copies and
I don't know that many of your viewers
including yourself have ever looked at
those things but they're too fat
ponderous volumes and they're dry dry
dry dry and so I was astonished that
they had sold over 20,000 copies how
much did he make off that's no way to
know that doesn't the records don't
exist to tell you that near the end of
his life what was it like at the end of
his life it was I think it was who was
very sad at the same time it was very
positive or sad because he and Brina
lived there at Beaufort Rina was not
happy at Beaufort it was isolated she
liked being in cities she also didn't
like the heat he was trying to form his
old plantation at bravia which he had
regained control of he was having a most
difficult time no success at all and
making bravia run again but at the same
time he was optimistic he really talked
about the United States and the growing
power its glory and grandeur he gave
talks to young people and he told them
that they should Revere
a Confederate heritage but they
shouldn't be mired in the past they
should look to the future United States
what did he die of probably pneumonia he
had contracted serious bronchial
difficulties in his probably pneumonia
killed him
this experience are you surprised about
anything overall the writing this is not
your first book no it's not my first
book by any means I I suppose of what
surprises me most is it through it all I
retain my fascination with this man I
think he's a fascinating person and this
cover of the book has the picture that
was taken when around 1861 right before
the breakup of the Union that's the
famous Mathew Brady photo when he would
have been how old here he would have
been let's see early fifties 53 William
Cooper junior author of Jefferson Davis
American thank you very much for joining
us